[Music]
g'day everyone my name's lucas
so
wi-fi it's great isn't it available
almost everywhere nowadays it lets you
look at memes from any location in the
world come look at this
surely there's nothing bad that can
happen from using wi-fi right if you
think so you must be new here welcome to
some sub your practical course on
survival in the deceptive digital world
now let's talk about wireless
connections
[Music]
i would like you guys to cast your mind
back to those lovely pre-covered days
you touch down at the airport of a
foreign country be it the us the uk
any place starting with you really or
any other letter
remember what would you always do when
getting off the plane first
even before you got to passport control
or get your luggage it's obvious you
would probably try to find wi-fi connect
and send off a couple messages to
friends and family order a taxi to the
hotel or check any emails that have come
through during a long flight personally
i like to search for the closest and
cheapest place for local cuisine eat
there and get sick immediately you
shouldn't do this not the food but the
wi-fi if you care about your network
security you definitely shouldn't
connect to unknown public networks in
the airport or anywhere else i'm going
to tell you why
on saturday february 20th 2016 barcelona
airport was crowded thousands of
participants for the mobile world
congress the largest exhibition of
modern electronics gathered in the north
eastern spanish city of catalonia the
exhibition organizers had planned and
arranged a fun interesting and
comfortable event
international journalists and the local
media were everywhere it was possible to
confirm registration and get
accreditation at the arrival lounge but
as a result of this
queues were piling up at the check-in
counters luckily for everybody there
were three convenient public wi-fi
networks working in the zone
simultaneously in four hours more than 2
000 people had connected to these
networks we know for sure that half of
them used an iphone slightly less than
half used the superior android
smartphone
and just a few were using windows mobile
and wearing their fedoras 62 checked
their email and searched for information
on google while 15
curiously preferred yahoo
50 people listened to music and podcasts
while they waited and more than a dozen
plan to arrange dates using tinder or
badoo how do we know that
the open networks these people connected
to had nothing to do with the coffee
chain the airport or the organizers of
the exhibition it's a trap it's a trap
the wireless equipment was brought in by
engineers from avast it was an
experiment they decided to set up free
wi-fi and find out how responsible
mobile market specialists are when it
comes to their personal phone's network
all data in these networks were scanned
and processed by specific traffic
analyzer programs a couple of days later
avast specialists share the results of
their experiments and the main sensation
was the statement that about 1 300
people that is approximately half of
those who connected to the wi-fi
lost their anonymity programmers managed
to get data about their names emails and
social network accounts we know all your
secrets of course our vast programmers
were not intruders thankfully they just
wanted to draw attention to how easily
even professional users of mobile
devices can fall into these scammer
traps the attendees of the event didn't
hesitate to connect to the networks
whose names seemed familiar or
understandable well
if mobile professionals can be tricked
so easily where does that leave courtney
when she's trolling for wi-fi at
mcdonald's at 3am in the morning in
addition if a hacker plans to attack you
specifically he can even copy the
identifier of a wi-fi connection that is
familiar to you for example your home or
office network and simulate its signal
elsewhere what this means is that when
you see a familiar network your
smartphone or laptop can automatically
connect to it thinking it is already
connected to one previously without
having you noticing to counter this
always manually manage the connections
of your devices to wireless networks and
disable wi-fi and bluetooth if you
aren't using them right here right now
now imagine you didn't connect to that
suspicious airport network instead you
decided to wait for the hotel where it's
nice and safe you are already in the
room looking at your tinder messages
wondering where the hell courtney is you
open up the list of available networks
and you see two possible connections a
familiar picture the hotel is large so
several different routers being used to
connect all the guests to the network
doesn't seem suspicious
of course most of us will choose the
network with the strongest signal
strength after opening it we usually go
to the page with the hotel logo which
will then ask us to identify ourselves
for example entering your first and last
name using your phone number or even
sometimes paying for the network
services with a credit card straight
away if you often like to travel
inexpensively then such actions have
most likely already become second nature
when traveling mobile data is gold and
anyone would try to save as much of that
data as they can this is doubly true
when we take into account roaming
charges everything would be fine but by
choosing the second network on your
phone in the hotel we fall into the
clutches of cyber criminals despite the
name and logo this chain has nothing to
do with the hotel it was created in
order to get your personal information
or plastic card data under the guise of
a regular service the attacker is
sitting in the room next to you perhaps
pouring poor courtney a glass of wine
while using a more powerful router than
the one installed in the hotel so the
honeypot network looks all the more
enticing it takes a few minutes to
simulate the hotel's login page and only
seconds to come up with an appropriate
network name well you see i'm not really
hacking the wi-fi i'm hacking you of
course so that you don't immediately
suspect fraud after entering the
requested data the attacker will really
connect you to the internet perhaps even
through a real hotel network but from
now on all traffic will be traveling
through the attacker's device first such
an attack is called a man-in-the-middle
attack or mitm for shorts the hacker
assumes the role of an unsolicited
intermediary and gets the opportunity to
analyze or falsify that data that you
are exchanging with others many people
believe that when using https sites data
is securely encrypted this is true but
only partially firstly without even
decrypting the traffic attackers can get
information that they will then use to
plan an attack
let the hacking begin for example they
can get a list of websites that you work
with or determine the size and type of
downloaded files the website data will
help to access your information in
social networks through the downloaded
files to slip in a file in a format
that's familiar to you secondly many
forms of encryption you may use can be
bypassed special programs allow
intruders to decrypt and substitute your
traffic
although this trick won't work so easily
with google or facebook services
other services are not so secure the use
of vpns which were described in our
video about ways to achieve network
anonymity will help protect you against
these types of traffic interceptions the
principal operation of a vpn is similar
to a proxy all the information exchanged
with sites on the internet go via an
intermediary server
all traffic through the vpn is encrypted
regardless of whether the wi-fi network
or the site you are working with
provides a secure connection even if an
attacker intercepts the information he
will not be able to analyze and decrypt
it successfully
[Music]
now i will tell you about another threat
that public wi-fi networks carry
the story of american entrepreneur noah
dinkin
is a cautionary tale of internet
security for all those who care to
listen a young programmer from new york
flew to buenos aires for negotiations
while waiting for the meeting noah
decided to get a pick-me-up by grabbing
himself a cup of coffee at starbucks at
the same time checking his email his
spider senses began tingling when he
noticed the delay with which the laptop
connected to the network about 10
seconds extra mysterious
noaa decided to figure out what went
wrong
to his amazement he discovered that
during this time his browser had
downloaded and launched a script for
mining monero it turned out that
hundreds of other visitors to the
archetype starbucks had over a cup of
coffee mine cryptocurrency for unknown
intruders
after 10 days it turned out that the
malicious code was added by a company
that provided communication services
but how long had lasted and how much the
scammers managed to earn is anybody's
guess
at the end of july 2021 the national
security agency put an end to the
disputes about the security of public
wi-fi points avoid connecting to public
wi-fi when possible they stated as there
is an increased risk when using public
wi-fi networks these recommendations
apply to all government officials law
enforcement agencies military personnel
defense contractors and people
associated with state secrets the nsa
recommendations do not guarantee
security but only mitigate the risk of
using wireless devices so
how can you protect yourself if you
still can't live without public wi-fi
networks
here is our list
firstly use a vpn traffic encryption in
a virtual network will significantly
complicate the life of attackers do not
enter unnecessary personal data on
internet authorization pages in a hotel
usually the room number is sufficient in
public places well your mobile phone
isn't going to see you get compromised
too badly
if the network does not allow you to
connect without specifying your credit
card number you can always use an online
credit card generator in advance don't
hesitate to check the reliability of a
network with the staff of the business
you're residing in
waiters in the restaurant the porter in
the hotel etc this way you can avoid any
of those nasty phishing networks i also
recommend disabling auto connection to
known networks in your phone and laptop
settings this will protect you from
duplicate wi-fi networks in case of any
suspicious behavior on your device or
phone programs long loading slowing down
overheating
just disconnect from these networks
immediately
coin hive has officially ceased its work
but dozens of other developers are
following in its footsteps regularly
update your operating system and
programs in large public networks
malware often tries to sneak into your
device through known vulnerabilities
like these street food guy who sold me a
kebab by offering me a free side of
chips don't use public networks to
perform banking transactions do not
enter passwords or send confidential
information via an app to access social
media networks and mail always use
two-factor authorization this will
protect your password against
interception and session copying and my
biggest advice to you all is to stay on
the sum sub channel don't eat late night
kebabs and follow along as we uncover
new predators in the online digital
jungle
take care of yourself your precious wifi
and your stomach i'll see you soon
[Music]
you